Instructor: We know
that var is function scope. We
know that let and const are
block scope, which is any time
you've got a set of curly
brackets. Now, we need to know
that inside of the scope where
the variable's declared, you can
only ever do that once. If I
try to go let points = 60 here,
it's not going to let me. It's
going to say points has already
been declared. Whereas with var
variables, it will just go ahead
and work for you without warning
you. That can cause a lot of
bugs in your actual applications,
because you might accidentally
use the same variable twice.
You can, of course, update a let
variable. We'll take a look more
at let versus const in the
future, but you cannot redeclare
it twice in the same scope.
Now, what if I had this? If
points > 40, we'll say let
winner = true. Give that a save,
refresh, no errors, it's allowed.
But if I type in winner, what am
I going to get? You tell me.
We get...Oh, but this runs. Does
this run? Console.log, it ran.
Let's see, did it actually run?
It ran. Why is winner still
false, if we set winner to be
true? The important thing
here is that these two variables
are two separate variables. They
have the same name, but they are
both scoped differently. This
winner here, that is scoped to
the window. This winner here,
because it was declared inside
of a block -- look this is a
block statement right here -- it
is scoped to that actual block.
If I change this let winner, and
I changed these both to be var,
and I type winner, winner is now
true. Why? Because it's not
inside of a function, it's not
scoped to it, whereas a let
variable totally is. That's one
thing to know about it. The
other thing we need to know
about it is that the difference
between let and const is that
const variables cannot be
updated. Let variables are made
to be updated. I may say points =
60, and that will work just fine.
We see 60. However, I've got
this key, maybe something that
you do not want to ever change;
const stands for constant. If I
try to update it -- key = a, b,
c, 1, 2, 3, 4 -- it's going to
yell at us because "assignment
to a constant variable." You
cannot update a const variable,
whereas let you can update.
We're going to go more into
examples of these and you're
going to understand where I use
which one as we go through, but
that's really all we need to
know about it for now. One
other quick thing is that
sometimes people think that
const means it's immutable,
which means that if I have an
object like const person =...
I'll say name is set to Wes and
age is set to 28, I've got this
person variable. But if I try to
update that to something else --
name is Wesley -- it doesn't
allow me to do that. However,
the properties of a const
variable can change. That's
because the entire object is not
immutable. It just cannot be
reassigned. The way I like
to think about it with an object
is that the person is me. I'm
not going to ever change, my
entire life, but attributes
about me are going to change.
Maybe my age, my hair color,
where I live. Things about me
are going to change. That's fine,
as long as the object that is
assigned to Wes is always the
exact same object. I can go
ahead and say person.age = 29
and then we have person. That
works just fine, but I cannot
ever wipe out the entire
variable. If you do need to
freeze everything, we have this
thing called object.freeze. It's
actually not part of ES6, but
you can take a look at it on MDN
and you can pass it person. Say
const Wes = object.freeze.
Now, I've got a Wes variable. If
I try to say Wes.age = 30 and I
type Wes.age, it still says 28.
I just can't actually change
anything on that actual variable.